why did you get back why did you go to
jail
[Music]
I'm fully aware that I would not have
been banned or canceled if I wasn't
Andrew's brother
if I had played things my way me and
Andrew would probably be back in jail
[Applause]
I jumped off the rock I'm not scared of
Jay
you want to send me back good because if
you send me back you're now gonna have
to explain to the world why
can they even do that like what is the
crime every story all the girls it's
only towards Andrew they don't care
about the truth they just want to spin
some negative stories they wanted the
Tate Brothers in jail
it's us against the world
[Music]
so when you hear the war Tate you think
about Andrew Tate but it's really the
brothers Andrew and Tristan Tate and
when I think about Tristan Tate I I told
him earlier I said you could have gone a
completely different ride the guy looks
like a Hollywood star he looks like a
movie star uh he looks like he could
have played James Bond maybe they
shouldn't even consider it unfortunate I
know they just made the announcement he
looks like a real James Bond dresses
like one
um has the personality of one the ladies
love them if you've never seen his
pictures just go on Google type in
Tristan Tate you'll see what he looks
like the looking guy but
he's got a completely different identity
to himself very different than Andrew we
had a very good time talking to Andrew
uh your brother and the way he built you
up today was very unique I've seen you
guys talk to each other about each other
but the way he did it today was very
different anyways Tristan it's good to
have you on the podcast it's good to
finally yes last time we met in Madrid
but we never did a podcast for about 60
seconds I was saying I was eating
Spanish paella the night before I
cracked one of my teeth and the next
morning Andrew wakes me up saying okay
let's go to Patrick's podcast and I had
this big swollen face so I hid inside of
my hotel but I did catch you for about
45 seconds by reception because we were
staying in the same place yeah and you
thought I'd been in the fight I thought
because you guys fight I'm like this guy
probably gotten too far apparently now I
know he lost her some muscles but not
the good kind of yes yeah not the good
kind so here's my question for you when
we read the stories about why you know
Andrew's Gone to prison or Andrew this
or this woman came out or that woman
came out why did you go to jail why did
you get banned why did they take your
Instagram down I mean I remember the
pictures it was all cars and suits and
motivational stuff so is it Guilty By
Association it is Guilty By Association
I hate to say it but I'm fully aware
that I would not have been banned or
canceled or probably ended up in jail if
I wasn't Andrew's brother but there are
so many benefits that come with being
Andrew's brother that you have to take
the Google
It didn't upset me too much no I smiled
about it what does this positive
attitude come from you could be the
victim oh Andrew you you did this yeah
you landed me in jail look at all our
assets are seized yet smile on your face
as gracious just humble guy where did
all this come from you know it's always
been the way me and Andrew are and we've
shared in our successes
um the first time he became first time
he became a millionaire we celebrated
when I became a millionaire we
celebrated when um you know we bought
our first Supercar we drove that home
from the dealership together so every
single positive moment in my life the
first time we ever charted a private jet
I remember we were just happy drinking
having a great time on the on the plane
this before he reverted before anybody
jumps on that drinking reference but if
you want to take all the good moments
from having a relationship a brotherly
relationship like me and Andrew have and
then he becomes the world's most Googled
man one of the most influential men I
guess in in the world and by default
he's attacked by The Matrix in a way
that and ends up with him being thrown
in prison I feel like I'd be more mad if
I didn't go to prison with him I'd feel
like you know I've taken all the good
from being associated with Andrew and
you know he builds me up and I build him
up and for him to be sitting in jail
without me it would just feel wrong so
I'm not even mad about it I'm the
opposite of mad about it I'm glad they
wrote me and I'm glad they said Guilty
By Association I'm glad they throw me in
jail with them and if they frame him for
real and send him back they better send
me back too or I'll break myself in you
make yourself I'll break into the gym
right you know seduce one of the prison
guards or something smart I can't see
you doing something like that I can't
see you doing something like that but
you did give a good book recommendation
earlier I appreciate that which was
great it's a inside joke but uh uh yeah
so going back to this whole story story
of uh I got confused right now because
you know we're both in a different place
I'm thinking number seven I'm thinking
eight and a half I'm in a whole
different place today okay well working
out is good staying in shape is good you
know all that stuff is a very good thing
so really don't want to talk to your
lawyers why why did you why did they put
you in jail I mean I know it's Guilty By
Association can they even do that like
what is the crime every story all the
girls it's only towards Andrew where are
you involved yeah well when digging
through Andrew's entire past trying to
find a reason to put him in jail what
you have to understand is
we have not been accused by X number of
women the prosecutor has accused of us
of doing X to X number of women these
women actually defend us actively one of
the statements in the file is a girl who
I used to date a little bit she details
nothing illegal says nothing illegal
went on she wasn't held against her will
she wasn't trafficked she wasn't
exploited but
because I used to sleep with her I guess
I'm guilty too so I mean I guess one of
the girls is my ex so that's the only
real link
um with me but yeah it's Guilty By
Association they wanted the Tate
Brothers in jail so when they came when
they came to arrest did they come to was
it was it you and Andrew it was both of
you yeah they had arrest warrants for
both of us and when they came to arrest
us what's very funny is my cousin's
girlfriend was here at the time with
with her friend there were actually
women in the house at the time the women
in the house were not questioned the
women in the house were not asked if
they were okay the women in the house
were not asked if they were in danger if
they were safe they were completely left
alone left to sit on the couch with us
um while the police watched over us well
they went through the house and took
everything that was valuable they were
Googling the value of the various items
they were taking marking it down on a
spreadsheet and they left I think
without saying a single word to the
women who were in this house which is
very unusual you would think an
investigation about human trafficking
but you know you could you could take
what implications from there you will
and guess what their motivation were if
you will but I'm I can't say anything at
the moment that makes sense so uh we
talked to Andrew earlier about his
experience in jail how was the
experience for you from your point of
view
ah well I mean Romania spends less money
per prisoner than any single country in
the European Union the the prisons are
constantly getting in trouble from the
European Union for being uh underfunded
uh too many people per room not enough
square meters not enough calories per
day so the jail experience
it wasn't good but it was interesting
and I took jail on a very strange way I
feel like
if you're gonna if you're gonna walk
around the world running your mouth all
the time about what you are and what you
think you are eventually something's
going to come along in the world and
test you if you walk around saying I'm
the baddest man on the planet I can beat
anyone up on Earth one day something in
the street is gonna be like ah you're
the guy who thinks he can beat anyone up
and punch your lights out
you know I don't speak as much as Andrew
but I do say I'm a very strong-minded
person I always preach to young men if
you're going through hardships you know
you need to deal with it like a man
continue your training stay focused and
it just felt like God gave me an
opportunity to prove to to myself above
all else as well as to everyone else who
listens to me that I am actually what I
say I am so coming out of jail
I'm almost grateful for the experience
as hellish as the environment was
as hellish as the environment was you
were grateful for yeah I'm grateful that
my life has been very very easy for the
last
six or seven years I retired from
professional fighting when I was 28. the
last sad thing that I guess happened to
me was my father passing when I was 26
and a half so I'm 34 now I'm coming up
35. these things happened a very long
time ago I've increased in wealth I've
increased in Fame I fly around the world
doing whatever I like driving whatever
car I like staying wherever I like
sleeping wherever I like going you know
it's been such an amazing experience
that I haven't tested myself for real in
a very long time so yeah grateful for
the experience and you had very high
praise about you right I mean we did a
whole segment about
he always thought you were the best
brother in the world but after being in
jail with you now he knows he's
confirmed and reaffirmed that you're the
best brother in the world and he almost
kind of compared you to like being the
the Ying to his yang right and I didn't
really fully understand who Teresa was
we've sat with Andrew for hours on end
we just had 45 seconds with you yeah
after that uh paella incident right
um but he says that your special gift is
the mat you've mastered the art of not
giving a [__] yeah what is that all
about well I'd say it's not not giving a
[__] in the way that because I know
people who don't give a [__] their life
sucks you know they don't work out they
don't care about their their own health
happiness wealth work uh not in a
degenerate I'm a bum kind of way I'll
give you a better example because I know
exactly what he means I feel like
because I am his younger brother every
great General who sits at a table with
his staff needs that one Fearless guy
with him you know he needs people who
preach prudence and being careful and we
have those people believe me they're
very very loud in our ears every single
day since getting out of jail but you
know if you're a great Samurai General
and you're sitting around the table you
also need that one guy who says okay
there's ten thousand of them there's
five of us okay let's just go
it's more fearlessness than than not
giving a [__] if I if I had played
things my way since getting out of jail
me and Andrew would probably be back in
jail right now I'm censoring myself on
this podcast but the first day I got out
I thought you know what screw it and
just put a camera on just tell the whole
world what's going on let them take me
away live on stream that's me so luckily
he keeps me in check but also I feel
like I can Inspire him to make a few
Bolder and braver decisions in life
because of my counsel so I'm very much
one of his councilmen but he does need
me at the table without that guy you're
just going to be a [__] you know have
you always played the number two role
like you know in in monarchical times it
was always the eldest son that the pet
was passed down to the crown from your
father down to Andrew to you has it
always been an understanding all right
I'm Number Two my brother's the leader
let me get in line let's crush it you
know what I I don't feel
it's necessarily it's necessarily like
that I feel it's more that I know what
his strengths are and I'm there to
compensate for his weaknesses he knows
what my strengths are and I'm there to
compensate for his weaknesses so who's
the leader and who's not all depends on
the situation that we're in
um certainly with
I mean me and Andrew have been a team a
very long time and we made a lot of
money before we ever blew up on the
internet uh our relationship was a lot
more equal then but Andrew is the famous
one I'm fully I'm fully aware that he's
the guy who will go in front of the
camera and say the types of things or
voice his opinions in a way that Garner
infamy uh and fame and I've blown up
alongside it so you know part of the
prices is going to jail you know they
say that uh
your ego is not your Amigo there must be
some part of you I mean you're a six
foot four badass good looking Hollywood
looking guy girls Bugattis yet you're
you're willing to
take a step back seat to Andrew's Fame
so you must you must have a big ego to
be the place that you're in but you also
have to have tickets step back and say
all right Andrew you're the guy how do
you grow up with that well yeah with
what we're doing now Andrew's certainly
the face of it but he wanted to build
this this was never my intention I
thought okay you're gonna make some
money on the internet that's cool Andrew
you do that I'll continue doing what in
fact I'm going to interject with another
story
there was a time when me and Andrew
could barely pay the rent he was
training and he was fighting full-time
he was a kickboxing one-time world
champion I think at the time and I was
selling Windows I'm a great salesman so
I was bringing home a thousand plus
British pounds per week he didn't tell
you this story did he no he said there
was a window yeah but he didn't say he
was balling out making a thousand no I
mean that's not bowling out like I think
these three glasses of whiskey cost
about a thousand dollars but I was
making about a thousand a thousand
British pounds a week uh Andrew had a
previous sales experience I was at the
time working in sales and Andrew was
just living off his fight money so I
would come home every day I said oh I
made this much sales Etc I'll pay the
rent you keep fighting because I was
helping to support his kickboxing career
one day Andrew looks at me and he says
you know Tristan I'm just gonna start
selling for the same company you're
selling for we could bring two three
thousand dollars into the house a week
we'll have a good life we'll make money
and I said Andrew no you can't
you can't do that because if you are
spending all your time chasing sales
leads and knocking on people's doors
like I am then you're never going to
find the time to discover something
better to discover something that's
going to take us out of this crappy
apartment it's going to take us out of
this crappy life so even back then when
I was willing to work away selling
Windows instead of kickbox because I got
paid almost nothing I was the European
champion at the my height my most I've
ever got paid was a thousand bucks a
fight I knew that wasn't the financial
viable uh option for financially viable
option for me I was willing to sell
Windows to let Andrew continue to have
time to train but also have time to
think so now everyone's like oh well
he's the face of this online Persona and
you know you guys make a lot of money
for it I'm like I'm fine behind the
scenes I'm perfectly perfectly happy I'm
not missing anything from my life with
my 2 million Twitter followers I need
6.8 million to fulfill you know people
will often try to
I guess pit me against Andrew which is
the stupidest idea in the world but
they'll say stupid things to me like
your brother's more famous than you and
I'll say yeah my brother's more famous
than you like what's the big deal if
your brother was or Mike Tyson for
example and someone said your brother's
bare boxing you you'd be like yeah my
brother's Mike Tyson what you know it's
this strange type of jealousy in envy
that I think a lot of men can't cope
with that makes them drag each other
down like crabs in a bucket if my
brother became the I don't know a
billionaire the world's richest man and
I had to stay at this level I'd be like
yeah my brother's the world's richest
man I'd be proud of him and I don't see
anything wrong with that it's not a
competition we're a team
I think that's a big thing so I got an
11 year old son and a nine-year-old son
okay and the perspective
to have there's got to be a also a
massive level of maturity of the younger
one towards the older one I'm the
younger sibling in my family my sister's
six years older well we got a very good
relationship in our family but the
wisdom of the younger is different than
the wisdom of the older right you're
more watching you're more like okay yeah
that's probably not a good idea I saw
that smack him upside that I shouldn't
do that okay wow that's pretty good that
leads to good praise or that that's good
yeah I don't like that I have no
interest in that okay I would have
probably done it this way but I get it
so you have a different optic right to
see different things at what point was
it when you're you know you're coming up
and you you guys are you were talking
outside and you're like Hey we're so
competitive that hey six years ago the
whole prank concept but we no longer do
pranks all this gun yeah we're a big
prank family ourselves
when was it and even maybe from your
pops did that drive you guys to compete
against each other or that the Dr did
that drive you guys to compete against
the world what was his selling point to
the two of you I I don't think it's
something that we learned from my father
okay my father didn't have a a brother
or or another guy in his life who were
close like me and Andrew I think it's
something that happened organically and
it's not so much
competition against each other in terms
of what I can do and he can it's more
like how much am I going to contribute
to the team that you don't so a perfect
example this house is set up literally
perfect perfect for it I'll come down in
the morning 7am Andrew's ass laptop
we'll go do there's an exercise we hate
doing you put 30 kilograms on a burpee
bar do the on a weight bar you do a
burpee lift above your head and you do
150 times it's tiring it's horrible so
I'll do them and I'll say you know
Andrew you're a [__] why haven't you
done it yet then he'll do them and then
I'll go do them again just because I
know of I do him he has to do it that's
not people could see it as two men
competing against each other or you can
see it as two men within the same house
getting stronger and pushing each other
to become stronger you know when we're
racing around race tracks we're both I
mean I guess professionally trained
drivers we have lost track experience
lots of Road experience
the fact that he will drive faster than
me will inspire me to do better in
myself then me and my brother as a team
are better drivers it's not too many
competing against each other
you know it's us against the world but
that's something that happened very
organically and he's always been the
better kickboxer you know I'm I'm bigger
uh by I mean maybe I'm probably fatter
love certainly got more muscle as well
but um people see me Smash the pads and
you know amateurs like a girl I knew
once said oh wow you hit the pad so hard
can you beat Andrew in a fight I'm like
no
no when I try to punch Andrew like I
punch nothing I hit I hit air and he
ends up counterpunching so he's always
been the better kickboxer but I can take
that and be like you know what good he's
the four-time world champion good that's
my brother and just be proud it's us
against the world
so that wasn't that wasn't Pops that was
more you guys it wasn't it wasn't my
anything my father naturally instilled I
mean he certainly wouldn't let us fight
and argue with each other he had some
unconventional punishments we were ever
arguing he'd lock us in a Cupboard
together to sit there and stare at each
other he told us that story he told you
that story there we go that way that way
you know it's true when you're sitting
staring at your brother because you guys
were acting up and fighting or whatever
you might want to implement this for
Dylan and Tico do it it works you're
staring at each other yes what did you
learn about your brother at that point
what do you think he learned about you
just sitting staring for hours on end as
a punishment I think you just realize
that the conflict has no benefit you're
gonna end up standing in that cupboard
that's the payoff for your conflict
there's no Victory competing against
your brother
and um you know we grew up in Luton as a
huge Asian a huge Asian diaspora I guess
lots of Indians lots of pakistanis lots
of Sikhs lots of Muslims and these
people work as a team it's the one of
the reasons they outcompete British
people native British people and almost
every single metric and we knew a guy
named Bali although I hope Andrew hasn't
told you this no so he had a he was a
lawyer probably 50 000 pounds a year and
he drove a four hundred thousand dollar
Ferrari I thought 400 000 pound Ferrari
and a 500 000 pound Rolls Royce
sometimes and we were saying like do you
think bali's a drug dealer what do you
think he's up to it me and Andrew at the
time you know had quite a close
Brotherhood and he looked at us one and
I said Bali how do you have all this
money how do you get these fancy cars
when you're just a lawyer and you're
relatively young he was like 26 27 but
five or six years older than I was at
the time and bali's exact answer was I
remember he said you white people are
stupid now I'm mixed race he wasn't
talking anything racial he was talking
about I guess native British people he
says you will have five Sons or your
father may have five Sons which for
someone in my culture he was a Sikh an
Indian Sikh from Punjab he said that's a
jackpot and this English man's five Sons
will all move out of the family home
they'll pay five rents probably to
people like me they'll take five
different student debts out go on five
different career paths they'll they'll
they'll set up they'll get five
different mortgages marry five different
women and never see each other again ECC
my father had five songs now I'm a
lawyer my my brother's a dentist my
father's an engineer my other brother
owns a construction company one of the
and every single skill set that they
needed to to flourish was within the
household so we all live in the family
home we pool our resources our women
work together and prepare food for us we
work uh and every time that we have uh
new children or the families expanded we
just expand the house my brother owns a
construction company and that in that
way as a group we have three Toyotas one
Ferrari and one Rolls Royce and we can
all use them anytime we like
and that was what introduced me and
Andrew because we were flat broke at the
time we had nothing to share uh to the
idea of certainly you know what if we
can buy a Supercar together one nice car
then we can just share that car and now
thanks to his car addiction we have I
don't know 40 plus minus the 10 or 11
that means temporarily seized by the
remaining government but um yeah it
introduced us I guess to the concept of
pooling your resources and sharing and
you know what he's 100 right that is a
lesson you can learn from the Indians
from the pakistanis because it's
benefited us massive and you guys live
together here in this amazing compound
and Andrew said he's foresees himself
living with you the rest of his days
yeah how much of a factor was those
stories from the Punjab guys to today in
Romania you know what that was massive
and I don't speak to Bali anymore so if
you're out there Bali yeah you're
listening you know thank you for that
um but you know people people will even
ask that nowadays the way that you know
when you're a high net worth individual
the way things are owned is very tricky
you know you don't want you know no high
net worth individual has everything in
his name let's just put it that way and
it's complicated the way things around
so sometimes people will ask me there'll
be five cars on the drive and you know
girls especially who are naive to these
things be like which ones are yours and
which ones are Andrews my honest answer
is I don't actually know let me I have
to look at the papers to work out
exactly what but it but it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter the keys are in
this box in that group and we can drive
them whenever we like and we never argue
because there's so many you know and
when you build that abundance and you
build yourself to the level of wealth me
and Andrew are what are we going to
argue about there were times when we
were kickboxing but we didn't have money
for food we used to eat cans of sardines
and there have been times spitting our
last can over plain rice so now people
be like oh that's weird that you share a
house with your brother I'm like it's
weird that you don't
you know I used to share my last can of
food with him and now we can't live in
the same house I've got nine bedrooms
it's not like we're cramped for space
and uh otherwise we just live in two
separate houses with four and a half
bedrooms each and we'll drive to each
other's houses every day it wouldn't
make sense there's got to be 100 trust
for this to work oh 100 which is what
you guys have but me and Andrew have a
100 very obvious yeah very obvious so he
he gave you some love what would you say
about him like from your perspective you
know what what strengths who is Andrew
to you and maybe what are some strengths
and things he does that the rest of the
world doesn't see that you know and
Andrew is the hardest working man I've
ever met even with the lifestyle he
lives now and as fun as it looks and it
is fun and all the fun [__] we do is
real
even if we are in a luxury hotel in the
south of France where you're paying ten
thousand dollars per room Andrew will be
up at seven o'clock in that hotel gym
he'll message me at 8 30. I'll wake up
next to God knows who whiskey spilled
all over the desk but again that
inspires me and to be like emergency
meeting in my room emergency meeting you
always say that so I'll go to his room
what's the emergency room and he'll
bring up tiny issues with the business
you know I could have slept on quite
happily but again it's like me doing the
exercise when he won it pushes me to be
a better person and Andrew will happily
work 15 16 hours a day and then go out
and spend four or five hours having fun
and blowing loads of money it doesn't
come from the sky it's not magic we're
not trust fun kids we didn't win the
lottery he is the hardest working man I
have ever met and the fact that I can
even live with him and try to keep up is
is is a testament to me because it's
difficult you know because it's
constantly yeah and people don't see the
work people don't see the work um I mean
me and Andrew we're in good shape I
don't post training videos and you know
Fitness progress videos I just do the
work and let the results speak for
itself in terms of money and in terms of
business and success that's Andrew
everyone's like oh well why does he have
all this money maybe he's a criminal you
know so uh how does he have all this
money I know why he has all this money
money because he's sitting right there
at that desk at least 10 hours a day
even when we're not on house arrest
he'll be out in the evenings having his
fun and that's what we'll show to the
world this whole hey look at me I'm at
my laptop and I'm going to grind away
for six hours I'm like that's no one
wants to see that on Instagram no one
wants to see that on social media it's
boring they want to see you driving the
Bugatti with a cigar in your mouth and a
beautiful girl next to you but that
doesn't come without sitting at that
desk for a good while first
when's the last time you told Andrew no
meaning hey I have an idea here's what I
want to do I'm the hardest working man
in the world here's what I'm doing I
have an agenda and you go no bad idea
let's do this instead do you ever tell
him no how does this work in this
relationship I guess the answer to your
question would be tell Andrew no why
you know we're two men with the exact
same vision aiming for the exact same
goal
oh it's that old saying with great power
comes great responsibility so telling
Andrew no you have to understand I'm the
only person in the world who can tell
him no ever since dad died it's me and
that's it so I'm not going to use that
power over something trivial over
something that is a recommendation if I
don't think he should do something I
just know when he really really
shouldn't do something and then I'll say
no but I can't I literally can't think
of an example
I can't
no I can't see I can't think of an
example where I've told Andrew no in the
last couple years
that's the dynamic of the relationship
between the two of you guys indeed but
he's also the only person who could tell
me now and he doesn't really tell me no
for anything you know I'm still 34 year
old man little brother or not he's 36. I
can make my own decisions and none of us
have the tendency to ever do anything
that's really stupid
so at the peak who was funner to party
with
no no don't worry about the peak I
haven't reached my Peak yet
like I'm still working on it I'm still
working on it yeah I'm the one Andrew
I'm the kind of guy I definitely take
the party a bit too far I'll give an
example go out to the club there's five
guys
15 girls we're all having fun all
parting Etc we'll come home Andrew will
be like okay well this is the girl I'm
with I'm gonna go to bed it's 3am I know
I could go to bed with one of these
women at any one time back in my party
days I've
I've calmed down a bit on the womanizing
I really have uh and he'll be in bed at
three I'll still stay up till six
drinking with the guys because I think
let me squeeze the maximum amount of fun
out of this night as possible
so obviously it gets ruined when it gets
to six o'clock and the girl I like is
now asleep or home and it's like oh wait
well you know I definitely messed that
one up but I'll certainly try to have as
much fun as possible and it comes back
to bite me sometimes but when's the last
time you parted you've been in jail you
haven't had one day of Freedom no no
right you guys are known as these
kickboxing badass womanizing party guys
but Andrew's been very subdued he's
converted to Islam what was that
drinking no he doesn't drink anymore you
had a fun night out of the Town a fun
night out on the town I don't know but I
had a fun night right here in my house
when my camera guy showed up I'm gonna
say his name his name's Bailey I'm going
to say I don't care he wants to say he
can't censor out don't give him
editorial control so he got here I
thought you know what Bailey's here
that's something new you know I've been
locked in jail now I'm on house arrest
let's open a bottle of champagne don't
worry baby just one four bottles of
champagne later Bailey's like wishing
for death I'm like you know okay fine
I'll let them go to sleep but we stayed
up all night talking politics history
very very interesting things along with
my my coach my physiotherapist Alex who
hates drinking by the way but he'll
partake sometimes and you know it was
just three guys together talking about I
feel like it's the way things should be
and the way things certainly were before
mobile phones nowadays everyone's too
connected digitally they speak to each
other online too much everyone WhatsApp
to each other checks on their friends
that way I like sitting around with my
friends and just drinking and talking
and having a good time and learning new
things from them and telling them new
things that they don't know I find that
to be incredibly
fulfilling so you were saying interest
you said Cutters you collect Cutters and
all this stuff I collect Cigar Lighters
and cigar accessories I'm a nerd about
my cigars I'm a real nerd about it I
tried my first cigar when I was 28. and
now I smoke a lot of cigars people will
accuse me of saying oh well you try to
teach values but you encourage smoking I
don't encourage smoking these are bad
for you
but if you do them train really hard in
the gym get as fit and strong as
possible at least try to compensate the
damage but yeah I'm a nerd about my
cigars I smoked my first woman I was 28
I had a car crash which stopped me from
professionally fighting I had some
surgery just a year and a half ago to
fix all that damage finally but I
thought I can't fight anymore I've
always thought cigars looked cool I'd
never smoked a cigarette or any kind of
tobacco product up until that point and
I walked into the Cigar Lounge I thought
oh look yeah this big Cuban Scott let me
buy one of these I had some money even
back then when I was 28 and I got this
cigar got about halfway through and my
head was spinning I don't know how I
drove home I felt horrible but yeah now
I smoke two three cigars A Day Sometimes
some days I'll go without smoking but
the accessories are what make it cool
you know even here on the table these
have been here since you're uh since
your podcast with Andrew but it's the
lighters I like the Cutters I like I'm a
real nerd about it before going out I'll
pack my cigar cases Etc ready for the
club yeah what's your preference what do
you call it what's your go to a cigar
cigar my favorite cigar is actually so
you have to liken them to Champagne
because most people won't know what
we're talking about if we do cigars I'm
going to make it more interesting people
who don't know champagne will say yeah
give me some Dom Perignon every single
time I don't even like champagne I don't
like any champagne but there are old
Frenchmen who know that there's a Vu
Cleco bottle that's better than the Dom
Perignon if it's the right year Etc so
with cigars everyone goes Cohiba when
you can buy Cubans when you're outside
the United States Cohiba is the Dom
Perignon of cigar's got the yellow label
Everyone likes Cohibas but this is not
my favorite brand of cigar but my
favorite is H upman now they have a
European name even though they're Cuban
because a German businessman started
that company in 1848 Cohiba was founded
in 1966 it has much more history behind
the brand a much better quality cigar in
terms of build and flavor and they're
about half the price but me smoking hey
Joplin's is not a budgetary decision I
mean I'll buy cigars from the 1950s I
smoke six seven thousand dollar cigars
just because I enjoy them but hey
Jumpman are by far the best brand hands
down
can I give a quick shout out real quick
sure I only smoke cigars with two people
their last name is either Tate
or sapala okay so shout out to Matt
sapola this you're gonna love this
the finest of gentlemen the Tates and
the Apollo that's it that's a quick
shout out I I I very rarely smoke cigars
but if I do it's with the table well
actually Matt sapola did a minute call
with uh Andrew last time I think using
my neck yeah and that a good
conversation together so uh going back
to you uh spiritually the take comes out
Andrew comes out recently announcing
he's a Muslim yeah right but in the
podcast with us he said you're you're
still a Christian yes what is that
conversation like between the two of you
well you have to understand if you are a
fan of Andrew who watches him on the
internet always converted to Islam
that's sudden it wasn't sudden it was a
journey that I saw him go on which
certainly lasted at least 10 11 months
up into the the day he converted
reverted according to Muslims I'll use
the proper terminology up until the day
he reverted I
became a Christian about six years ago I
spent a lot of my life as an atheist and
I'm so ashamed to say that I don't like
the word I think it's a bad word
nowadays because I was young and naive
and stupid enough I think that people
could be perfectly moral and live in a
perfect harmonious Society without the
need for religion and about six or seven
years ago I looked around the world
literally at what people were doing the
massive fetishization I'll go I'll call
it of abortion
um you know the the degeneracy in
society and everyone's an atheist I
thought are these my people and I was
living in Romania the most Orthodox
Christian country in the world my
daughters maternal grandfather is
actually an Orthodox Christian priest
and I picked up the Bible again and I
read it from cover to cover front to
back and that was six years ago when I
became a Christian now ever since
Andrew's reversion
I have not spoken about my religious
beliefs because there are teams on
Twitter so you guys get the exclusive
there are literally warring tribes on
Twitter of Christian
Trolls let's call them and Muslim trolls
all fighting for my soul Tristan what do
you believe in Trista and I haven't
mentioned my religion ever since
Andrew's version of Islams there are
people who think I'm a Muslim there are
people who know I'm a Christian
but
for me the values that are shared
between the two faiths are both contrary
to everything what Andrew would call The
Matrix is trying to shut down young
people's throats and trying to program
people to believe
uh I think the days of of Christians and
Muslims murdering each other in Crusades
and um you know trying to take the whole
holy city of Jerusalem Etc are over I
think that there are ideological
differences and there are ignorant
Christians who will be like oh yeah but
you know Islam's a fake religion but
then there are ignorant Muslims who'll
say oh Christianity is a fake religion
good you're supposed to think that
they're different religions and they do
teach different things they have
different Messengers and they have
slightly different messages but as a
whole I'm perfectly happy living in a
house when my brother is a Muslim
because one I respect his decision two I
understand why he reverted three I
understand that we have a common enemy
in
uh we have an enemy in common and we
have the exact same goals I feel like
the religions now should be closer than
ever before it's fine to say you believe
things about God that I don't and I
believe things about God that you don't
but can we at least
agree that this is wrong and I feel like
Common Ground would unite Christians and
Muslims hand in hand if people were less
standoffish so I have no problem with my
brother being a Muslim he's quit
drinking I have lost my drinking partner
and the only reason I'm actually talking
to you about religion and answering
these questions because I kept it very
close to my heart and I haven't spoken
to anybody about it is because I am
publicly drinking whiskey well so you
need a new drinking Partnerships and I
can help you out here absolutely and
you're Jewish yes
Muslims refer to Christians and Jews as
people of the book that you have to
understand that Muslims hold Christians
in in very high regard so I've read even
since getting out of jail I've read four
books on Islam since getting out of jail
and I was actually quizzed by a Muslim
scholar who lives in the united
refer to Islam
and I said to him I said reversion or
conversion to any religion I don't
believe it's something that you do I
believe it's something that happens to
you if you look into a subject and you
read about you read the Bible and you
read about you know Christianity and you
read about the life of Jesus Christ you
don't think you know what yes I'm a
Christian I feel like it's something
that would have to happen to me not
something I choose to do and I've even
had people say oh you know your life
would be better if you revert to Islam
because
um you know there'd be benefits of you
living in the Middle East Etc I said no
no how disingenuous would that be to my
Muslim friends and colleagues of which I
have many to revert for any beneficial
reason other than me genuinely feeling
it within myself
so that's the reason I haven't not
because I haven't chosen to but because
it hasn't happened to me right so that
means it could happen yeah absolutely
right absolutely you said it's so
interesting you just said something
earlier real cool real brief you tweeted
out you said positive pregnancy test
question mark yes unsure what to do this
is the sign you were looking for keep
the baby yes raise the baby by the time
they are two you will thank God you read
this and shuddered that you ever
considered an abortion I understand you
have a choice but make the right one yes
I did tweet that because I understand
that there is now a chance with 1.8
million people following me on Twitter
and five six hundred seven thousand
hundred thousand people watching each of
my tweets that I may have just saved a
life
I wasn't trying to make any point
about the legality of abortion because
everyone's arguing underneath the Tweet
oh it should be legal it should be
illegal I will actually upset both teams
because I'm not pro-life or pro-choice I
believe that abortion should be legal
under many circumstances and there are
many reasons why there are people that
there are people in the world who for
many reasons would need an abortion what
I do is I don't try to force my views on
anyone else so my view on abortion is
very simple I'm against abortion for me
I've made lots lots of money I'm a smart
guy I'm a great dad if I get some girl
pregnant even if it's by accident it was
my choice to sleep with her and I'm
gonna make sure she brings that baby
into the world and take care of it for
the rest of its life so I'm against it
for me I don't try to force my views on
other people because otherwise we're
going to start this whole debate it's
going to happen in the comments section
of this video but what if a woman gets
raped I'm against abortion being used as
a form of contraception so I'm on
neither team so both teams can get mad
at me and I don't really care but yeah I
just thought with so many followers
maybe maybe I'm gonna get a letter in
the mail in 17 years time from somebody
whose mother's gonna tell them the story
of the time she read Tristan Tate's
tweet and I thought that would be
awesome wow so that was my motivation I
wasn't trying to start a political
argument because I really don't care
enough about these issues to debate
people on them because I know how I want
to live my life and if you're a crack
addict on the streets of New York and
you end up pregnant through sex work I
do believe there is a case where you
personally
don't need to be bringing a baby into
the world so I'm not going to tell you
it's illegal so I'm in the middle so
everyone can be mad at me everyone can
hate me do you like the bit
oh I I love debates do you like it as
much as he likes the way it's oh I love
debates okay so you love the boots okay
so politically uh you know when you when
you think about like are you following
politics closely do you watch the
election do you following the election
closely I do I do yes what do you look
what do you think about the elections in
the U.S right now
oh and the conditions in U.S politically
Jesus I feel like
both teams have
psychos that they need to Pander to to
the point where the whole process has
become absolutely ridiculous I feel like
the right have fewer psychos or less
extreme that they have to Pander to than
the left but you take people who say
very normal things and again this is
going to get me in trouble like men
can't get pregnant and people who've
been alive since the 1950s since the
1960s people who know that's not true
now have to pretend that they think it
is true and I'm like I'm not going to go
into what you think about foreign policy
I'm not going to go into what you think
about the issues America is facing
because you just said men can get
pregnant so you're an idiot and I feel
like the pandering to all these special
groups whether it be the the military
industrial complex that's not must not
go down that road
um or you know the the insane I won't
say the lgbtq and say people I'll say
the QT plus people because I think
lgbtqt plus should be completely
separate things
um yeah it's very hard to take any
American politician seriously I do know
who I want to be the next person of the
United States you probably know who I
want to be the next president
[Laughter]
oh yeah
um
I was gonna say
the audience doesn't know this when you
walk in here there's a uh is it six feet
or eight feet painting of President Joe
Biden I was so impressed the fact that
you guys have that kind of Pride for us
in the house well you know I'm not very
good at darts so I need a big board
would you say you were born in America I
was born in the United States raised in
the UK I'm English you consider yourself
I would consider myself English British
I'm proud to be English I love English
History as a mixed race person I like to
be able to stand up and say I'm very
proud of British history and we should
all be proud of our heritage without
people being able to point the finger at
me and call me a racist because when
white English people say that suddenly
they're racist for some reason uh yeah
super proud to be British I think that
the influence that the British have had
on the world is incalculably larger than
almost any other culture
um please correct me if I'm wrong um a
lot of the Great Inventions in the world
were British uh the way that you go to
every single country in the world and
they're all speaking the language of one
tiny Island in northern Europe why you
know it's it's I'm a proud Englishman
and I don't care about the United States
so much because I left when I was eight
years old if you want a guaranteed way
to get in touch with me maybe you have a
business idea maybe you want some
fashion tips maybe you just want to
connect you could find me on minute how
how interested can I be as much as I'm
interested in the nerdy way that I'll
follow it and know what each team has to
think if I've never worked a job in
America I've never had a girlfriend in
America I'm not educated by the American
school system I don't have a business in
the United States never had an American
girlfriend oh no I've had loads but
I've never had to manage a relationship
while living in the United States so um
how much what do I really have invested
in who wins the election you know as
much as I'm interested in it I consider
myself British and I care much more
about England which is a lot more [__]
up in the United States in lots of ways
it's failing in every single metric
which makes me sad would you say you
follow British politics even more than
American dollars no American politics
because it's more interesting the
British politicians are all all rubbish
and because of the electoral system
where the Prime Minister comes from the
party who has the most seats and each
seat is an individual election with the
first pass the post system there's no
winners nobody nobody can come along as
a hero let's say hypothetically because
I don't want to I don't want to say who
I support for president but let's say
hypothetically some billionaire
businessman with Charisma came along and
said I want to become the leader of
England he's got no chance he'd have to
start his own political party he'd lose
in every single individual election in
every single constituency in the United
Kingdom and you'd never hear from them
again I think it was in 19
I don't want to say the exact day
because someone's going to correct me on
it but it was in the 1970s the green
party of England won 20 something
percent of the vote and got zero seats
in the House of Parliament that's the
way the system works there so no hero is
coming along to save the UK which is sad
because I feel like both political
parties I could possibly win and both
their leaders are equally horrible what
you're saying is only in America yeah
exactly something like that possible
yeah exactly in England you've got two
dead horses and the race is about to
start why watch I'm not interested you
know and nobody else is either I
actually have another question for you
so we all have our nicknames right yeah
pbd right so your brother is Cobra Tate
you
are the Talisman yeah okay I actually
had to Google what the Talisman was
right so it is a an object
that has magic power and brings good
luck yeah right and keeps evil away and
protects
the person wearing it from illness
accident disgrace and Misfortune
absolutely right so how did you get the
name the Talisman and are you Andrews
Talisman I absolutely am but it wasn't
Andrew who gave you the nickname I was
17 years old and I was working at a
sandwich shop and I used to hang around
with this African guy from the Ivory
Coast Republican Luke if you're watching
God bless you I don't know where you are
today
and we go out to various bars and we
would um anytime he'd see attractive
women because I mean I'm 17 what do you
know you know of course I'm out there
trying to be women
and every time there was a group of
attractive women I go over and approach
him and I wasn't I mean how smooth can a
17 year old be but you know girls tended
to like me and he called me his talisman
you know I I don't know if it was his
his lack of English that made him use
the word Talisman instead of good luck
charm but he would also call me his
Talisman and it was the Talisman and
that stuck and then I needed the fight
name and it was Tristan the Talisman
Tate and I feel like if you are my
friend if I truly care about you whether
you are pursuing a new goal in business
whether you are attacked on the street
having me by your side is a I'm a good
person to have by your side and I've
proven that hundreds of times to every
single person who I hold dear so I like
that name because it suits who I am you
know I say that in every single photo if
you see me and Andrew together I'm
always walking behind him and believe me
I'll hit someone faster than the
bodyguards with us will I'm that guy so
I like the nickname and I think it suits
me very well so you're Andrew's Talisman
yeah well then how would you be worse
off anything you want to do in life how
would you be worse off if I was fully
invested in the idea that you had and I
was on your side 100. yeah how would I
make you worse so I feel like that I'm a
very well-rounded person and it's not
just for Andrew it's for anybody I
choose to associate with or anybody I
choose to do business with so um or
protect or you know certainly five years
ago when I was a bit more wild if you
wanted to go out womanizing I'm I'm
pretty good at that too so I bring you
some luck in that department sign right
here so yeah no no retired from that
who's your talisman
in in what business it varies because
life is the hardest thing to find in
life is a flag carrier it's the hardest
thing to find is a flag clearance yeah
flag here you find a flag carrier that's
fully with you and then the time span of
how long that person is going to be with
you it's you look at Elon Musk right now
who's his talisman
[Music]
I absolutely love Elon Musk and I shut
down any criticism I see of him online
because I don't think people are I don't
think almost anybody is in a position to
criticize Elon Musk I'll give you an
example Elon Musk was dating to that
singer Grimes whatever her name is and
some dork who fancies himself a dating
coach on Twitter I'm not even gonna say
his name because that would do him a
massive favor I was like oh yeah Elon
Musk really needs to book one of my
calls for 29 for half an hour so I can
give him dating advice I'm like
who are you Elon Musk is arguably one of
the world's most powerful men he has the
power to send things into space and
bring them back one of the first
independent human to ever have that
power outside of being a government
he's insanely intelligent he takes on
tasks like I mean Tesla automobiles
absolutely rubbish idea if you were to
pitch it to anyone many years ago and he
turns them into successes Elon Musk is a
different breed it's like a bunch of
chihuahuas you know saying laughing at
Lions laughing at Tiger stripes saying
that his coat is wrong like who are you
to criticize him in any way he doesn't
need your dating advice the man's got 10
kids
nine rest in peace and that must have
been hard for him God God Bless but like
how are you some dork on the internet
going to criticize him in any way who is
going to give a [__] about you 50 years
from now 100 years from now 300 years
from now if Elon Musk keeps going the
trajectory that he is going he will be
one of the most remembered people of our
entire generation yeah Barack Obama was
the first black president of a country
that used to be called the United States
you know now uh West China I'm joking
I'm joking but but in 500 years on a
thousand years time the guy who
revolutionized space travel and took us
from a single planet wow yeah from a
single planet species to a
multi-planetary species that's his
name's gonna be in the history books no
question long after everyone else's so I
don't even like anyone criticizing him
in any way so if you have anything bad
to say about Elon Musk
but I will say this I didn't get a
chance to ask your brother this but you
know since Twitter's the only platform
yeah and your brother are allowed on yes
right
he's what he's done for free free
speeches again he's incredible yeah uh
and you know he's also a customer
customer service representative yeah
it's very interesting
um your brother tweeted back to Elon
Elon tweeted famously I think I'm going
to remove accounts that are inactive
yeah aren't tweeting anymore yeah and
your brother didn't didn't bash him said
great idea Elon yeah but it is I have a
suggestion my father passed away what
seven years ago maybe eight years ago
I still read his tweets all the time I
would really appreciate if he would keep
his account active yeah as of today I
think his account is still and he's
still active so
um
thoughts on that the fact that Elon Musk
possibly read your brother's tweet well
he he's like kept it active well he's
liked some of Andrew's tweets before but
you have to understand and I fully
understand I don't have an ego I fully
understand if you don't know me and
you've never met me and you listen to
what the prosecution service of Romania
is saying about me even if you like me
and even if you don't believe it the
smart choices wait for it to be proven
[__] [__] before interacting
with me you know because
an association I would not want to be so
associated with somebody who was a human
trafficker I wouldn't so I get it if
someone doesn't actually know me and
they're like oh well let me distance
myself from Tate right now yeah it's sad
and yeah most people who have their
[__] detector switched on can know
what's happening to me and why or to
Andrew and why but he's liked some of
Andy's tweets but he doesn't follow us
and he doesn't interact with us besides
those likes and I completely understand
the decision because what if tomorrow
photos of a room behind that room come
out with chains and mattresses where
people were kidnapped and kept you know
the kind of evidence you'd expect in a
case like this you know what if that
comes out yeah I saw none of that by the
way uh yeah no you have to type in the
special code
but anyway so yeah no Elon is a is a
wonderful guy and I think he's kept
Andrew's um account upon purpose if I
could give Elon one piece of advice I
have actually criticized people for
giving Elon a people uh Elon advice but
there is one thing one thing that he did
that I think he could have done better
hear me out you are the only man
in human history
ever to have the power to send things
into near Earth Earth orbit without the
government it's just you if you send
something up that people don't like who
has to take it down the Russian
government the United States government
I get that he sent a Tesla I get it but
I have criticized them on this before I
would send a statue of myself saying
Elon owns space and I publish its
coordinates every day on the website so
people on their telescopes could look
with a giant statue of myself that will
be up there forever longer than humans
will live on the earth that will be up
there who's gonna take it down if you
troll the American government with that
statue into sending up a giant satellite
with a net to bring down your Elon own
space statue that's a double win so I
get that he sent the Tesla but if I
could give him one piece of advice just
one send a statue of yourself yeah you
know what and you don't even have to
reply to this podcast Elon but if you do
it I if you do it I will donate a
million dollars to a charity of your
choice
I promise that is I absolutely promise
if he sends a statue into space saying
Elon owns space it has on a live feed I
will donate a million dollars to any
charity that's not even criticism that's
just friendly advice that's that no
that's elon's more mature than me and
I'm childish and I would have done
something more challenging so it's not
even advice it's me admitting that I'm a
I'm a bit of a little kid about things
sometimes and uh yeah I'm pettier than
Elon I guess so it's not advice in the
positive at all but that's what I would
have done differently he he is capable
of doing something like that I know if
there's a guy that would do this
probably him I know and I hope he does
were you here on BBC came here
I was here I was that experience I know
they were very friendly and you guys
check them on their vaccines and masks
and everything how was that entire
experience from your your Optics
I I love that people underestimate both
my brother and myself they see a bunch
of money and they see fast cars I don't
know how they think I got it I don't
know if they think I'm a thug a criminal
a trust fund kid I've heard all the
theories but nobody actually understands
that Andrew and I are very intelligent
people I don't know why the people who
hate us assume that we're done oh
they're kickboxing they're gonna punched
in the head a few times they're probably
thugs they have no idea that woman was
totally unprepared for who she sat down
across from
she was unprepared she could have done I
mean I think you famously put out she
did no more than five hours of research
I think less than that but she could
have sat and watched every single word
Andrew has ever said and came with the
same attacks and looked equally as
stupid I feel like the BBC know this I
don't think the BBC is an institution or
as stupid as people are making them out
to be I think that the woman they sent
they knew was unprepared they don't care
how many views are on that video
compared to all the other views they get
now unfortunately the TV no one who
wants news goes home at nine o'clock and
turns on BBC anymore it's all internet
it's all clicks Tucker Carlson is wiping
the floor with everybody at the moment
and God bless him he's doing a wonderful
thing but they sent her like a land to
the slaughter I really believed that the
top of the top BBC Executives have to be
smart enough to know that this woman was
not an intellectual match for Andrew
Tate they must have known they've seen
his previous interviews but this woman
didn't know and it was frankly
embarrassing for her I was standing
right here on this balcony listening to
the entire thing was happening right
here and I felt embarrassed for her yeah
clearly she had an agenda clearly they
lost what I thought was pretty pathetic
is even if you have an agenda even if
you don't agree with the person
at the very least shake the person's
hands yeah why wouldn't she Shake either
of your guys hands on the end of the
interview that's just low class yes it
was and it was the fact that if she
feels if she had felt that she'd got the
better of him she would have shaken his
hand she absolutely she clearly lost yes
because she shook his head in the
beginning
so let me ask you so clear the air if
they're if they're accusing you if they
don't know how you make money you guys
run the real world you guys want to run
the War Room uh Justin Waller if we were
saying nice things about earlier shout
out to Jay Waller yeah
last week I'm gonna allow you to clarify
I said last week I put out a challenge
for any student of the real world to pay
the next month's mortgage for their
parents yes
he gave an example of a guy named so did
our Shadow 2 came through yes for his
mother he could not be more proud of
this young man I know covertate and the
Talisman would feel the same so here you
are changing actual people's lives
enabling young men to pay their parents
mortgage yes what are you doing with the
real world what are you doing with the
war room that's actually enabling people
to help their family to make money and
as a byproduct obviously you guys make
money well the real world is a is it
it's a I think it's a almost a
revolution in education which is another
reason why I think everyone wants Andrew
to shut up I feel like the traditional
way because you have to understand
universities have a monopoly on the
borrowing credit of young people an 18
year old who wants to be a pilot cannot
say hey back give me some money so I can
take some flying lessons and get my
pilot's license they'll say no join the
military or don't he can't say I've got
a great business idea give me a loan I'm
gonna start an ice cream store here's
the business plan they'll say no hey I
wanted to study gender studies give me a
hundred thousand dollars boom they write
the checks every single time and the
people you're learning from are not
necessarily qualified to make you a
better fit for the workforce they're not
necessarily qualified to teach you
anything about how to make money which
used to be the end goal of University
I do not sit on University
my doctors went to University my lawyers
went to university university is
absolutely necessary in today's society
but telling every young person that's
the only path to success the real world
was founded on the principle that when
me and Andrew were young we had to jump
through hoops to network with high-level
people my dad knew a rich chess player
this guy ran a kickboxing tournament
okay let me see if I could speech him
for 10 minutes after see if I can learn
anything now 49 a month you are in
direct contact with millionaires who
we've all verified we verified them
personally people who have made millions
of dollars in their industry and they
are going to teach you how they they did
it and what you should do if you wish to
emulate them so we're cutting out the
middleman in a way so it is absolutely
wonderful do some people join the real
world and just have it on their phone
and think it's magic I think it's going
to make the money and not make money
perhaps it's a resource like anything
else like a great book but you have to
put the time in you have to learn the
knowledge from it and yeah that guy paid
his mother's mortgage payments the
difference between the real world and
the War Room the war room you have to
think of it more of but as a as an as a
private members Network whereas the real
world nobody's vetted nobody is kicked
out anybody who wants to jump in at any
point man woman or child any of any age
can can get inside and learn from the
people who are professors in the world
uh in the real world let me see I just
mix them up just there why the name's so
similar whereas the war room is
something very very different um
I'll let Andrew's probably given a
description of the war room and I feel
like that will be adequate so I'll leave
it at that because I am just a war
remember like everybody else I do not
own the War Room
so this whole time I thought you guys
might have been 50 50 Partners on all
this is all Andrew Well 50 50 Partners
on everything you are yeah if I if I go
if I if I went outside right now and I
don't know did anything that made money
it goes into the same Banks it goes into
the same accounts anything any of us do
goes into the same banks in the same
accounts and you know when you're
successful enough that's hard to keep
track of it's not just one account with
one number it's all over the world so
all of our money is is collective money
so it doesn't matter what he earns what
I earn because it all goes into the same
place
warwoman real real world real world yeah
how many how many total members do
kavanizes I think I think the real world
where we have in excess of 200 000
students holy 200 000 students
absolutely very impressive and then for
anybody who can do basic maths you know
to assume that I would need to kidnap
anyone to make money is ridiculous I'll
just leave that out there but you know
the people who are involved in this
attack don't care how I make money they
don't care in the truth they don't care
about the truth they just want to spin
some negative story about me and I feel
like they failed but we'll see we'll see
what happens time time will tell the way
it's going right now you're gonna see
what's going to happen here soon but I'm
not afraid of anything they can't stop
me have you ever been a child
and found something scary I have an
example I was living in Indiana seven
years old and everyone was jumping into
this Lake from this big tall Rock and I
sat there all day and all afternoon
while everyone jumped off this big tall
Rock I walked to the edge of it five or
six times and I thought you know what
that's scary I'm not going to do it and
by the end of the day I jumped and
thought oh well that was no big deal
then did it again again then it was time
to go home I was no longer afraid of
that the worst punishment these people
can do is to try to discredit spread it
by name which fails and to put me in
jail I've jumped off the rock I'm not
scared of jail anymore you want to send
me back good because if you send me back
you're now going to have to explain to
the world why you're gonna have to show
the evidence this time
so
you better prove it
you know whether I get sent back or not
they're going to have to finally show
their cards they've been sitting here
with a seven and a two while I'm across
them with Aces and there are aces all
across the floor and they've been chip
leader pushing their chips around making
their power moves the time is coming
where they're going to have to put their
cards on the table it's gonna be tough
for them yeah it's gonna be really tough
with them by the way were you here when
uh well I'm assuming you were here when
the I think it was Andrew who showed the
clip where he agreed for the vice guy to
come here
is this a true story yeah there was a
event that the War Room held called the
test nobody knew why they were coming or
what they were doing and Andrew matched
them up in a professional fight on no
notice because everyone likes to talk
big and say I'm ready and I've been
physically training Etc and people could
either pass the test by getting in the
cage or fail the test by by denying it
the vice guys went through the test and
the entire time he went through the test
he was like this is awesome yeah I
understand how this helps men grow and
Etc gave me all the [__] in my ear I
knew he was a snake from day one called
him out on the podcast so this guy's a
complete dork and he's not to be trusted
now Andrew ran this idea by everybody
the people who are careful my legal team
my PR team some of them are here and a
lot of people said no don't do that no
no no you look like a bully you'll look
like you're mean I was like this guy
when we were in jail released the most
biased piece of negative journalism I've
ever seen against us screw this guy and
he was like really I said yeah go for
Andrew I was that guy who said who can
what's he gonna do break into my house
pass my security guards and somehow beat
me up now we would have loved to fly to
Australia or Thailand and stand him up
there so he's got a nice you know
16-hour economy flight home but sadly
all we could do is book a rest and I
thought it was absolutely hilarious he's
he's still begging for an interview by
the way even today how long was he
waiting outside oh he came back twice uh
he wasted the whole day but outside of
my gate and physical hours spent maybe
three
shame what's happened to Vice George
Soros buying them out for 400 million
yeah well people deserve it they you
know what goes around comes around you
want to be a little jerk people are
going to treat you like one
they certainly won't forget how you
treated them people will not forget
absolutely they never do speaking of
what goes around comes around you know
there's there's two
probably the two most famous brothers in
the world these days you get the Tate
Brothers yeah and you get the Paul
brothers and there's been some some beef
some words exchanged yeah no love lost I
don't know certain people have said
certain things about one another
let's just say you're in a bar
you know there's no cameras there's no
judges there's no rules
Tape Brothers walk in the bar Paul
Brothers walk in the bar
who walks out
me and my brother every single time
but
I understand that this question is is
phrased to Hype the beef between us and
the Paul Brothers I actually want to put
one thing straight I have no beef for
the Paul brothers and I don't think my
brother does either I will go as far as
to say I really like Jake Paul me and my
brother are bigger than the Paul
Brothers more fight experience than the
Paul Brothers I've taken more more
punches in the Paul Brothers
um wrestling grappling me and Andrew a
judo experience like who would win the
fight I feel like that's a juvenile
question to ask because if I saw Jake
Paul I'd buy him a drink I like Jake
Logan not so much but Jake is a
hard-working young man who has put it
all on the line and gets in the ring
against people vastly more experiencing
themselves in Combat Sports he thought
Tommy Fury who was a vastly more
experienced boxer and I don't feel
there's any beef between me and the Paul
Brothers I sat down and had drinks with
Jake I would go as far as to say I like
Jake I don't like their relationship
with Brothers if I could criticize
anything about yeah I saw I mean there
are Clips when Jake's like oh I want to
be the world champion of boxing and
Logan's like yeah yeah good luck yeah as
if I don't feel that's a good way for
brothers to behave but more of that
comes from Logan to Jake there is no
there is no beef well there was beef
between your brother Andrew yes and look
there was actually I mean they probably
hate each other now but it but it
doesn't matter I remember a year ago
Logan Paul saying oh Andrew's the big
fish now but we'll see in a year where
he is and now no one cares who Logan
Paul is so you know no one who doesn't
drink his cheap sugary energy really
cares who he is
um and you know I think in five years No
One's Gonna know who he is but Andrew's
still going to be relevant wow so but I
think that's how the the victory is
going to be won but I I don't think
about the Paul Brothers I haven't talked
about them in a long time but I have
spoken to Jake since getting out of jail
and I will say right now I like Jake and
I like Logan for one thing and one thing
only Logan brought back with that loser
KSI this old notion of okay we've got
beef well instead of rapping about each
other or you know talking [__] on Twitch
streams let's handle it like men and
that's how that's how I grew up I grew
up in a very bad part of town and you
know I've had 40 something professional
fights myself that's how beef was
settled between men nowadays everyone
wants to stab each other or just talk
[__] and not actually back it up Logan
and KSI brought back the tradition of I
challenge you to adore so I feel like
Logan has given something great to the
world even though I may personally
dislike him a little bit and Jake I have
nothing bad to say about so I know
that's a boring answer no it's all good
I respect Jacob well in the last
interview we did your brother called out
Logan pretty hard and then the last time
we saw your brother out in public there
was a Face-Off between him him and Jake
him and yeah because there was talks of
a fight at the time gotcha I think any
certainly any plans to join in on the
YouTube boxing Community were thwarted
by our arrest in our imprisonment but I
also feel right now and I'll say
unapologetically to anybody involved in
that industry YouTube boxing's dying it
was fun for a while it was a spectacle
for a while I think it's dying I think
people want to see Jake versus KSI Jake
will kill him by the way
and after that no one really cares
anymore
I think that you can only put a
spin on boxing for so long but you're
never going to be the traditional this
guy's trained 15 years against this guy
was trained 15 years old school rules of
boxing I've actually likened YouTube
boxing to celebrity sex tapes hear me
out lots of people watch pornography
which is Haram by the way don't watch
pornography it's one of the worst habits
that men could possibly have but lots of
people watch this stuff of professionals
having sex with each other okay a
celebrity sex tape comes out crap sex
God's got a small dick but everyone
watches it why because it's a novelty
it's entertaining for a very short time
Kim Kardashian got famous that way
Pamela Anderson Paris Hilton back in the
day that was a big deal oh look it's
novelty it's poor
poor someone we know someone who
is of someone who seen speak on tv
YouTube boxing had its Big Moment Like
celebrity sex tapes had their big moment
and now people are bored of watching
losers with small dicks and they want to
see the guys with the big dicks [__] so
now I think people want to see real
boxing again and everyone's bored of
this well I know him a bit so I'm gonna
watch two idiots elbow each other in the
face because they don't know how to
throw a bunches straight well just so
you know right now the moment Tommy Lee
sees this he's going to be very upset at
you I'm trying to say what you said
about him because when the sex tape with
Tommy Lee and Pamela came out I haven't
seen it I know yeah I haven't seen it
Tommy Lee has got a respect in the
market Tommy Lee known commodity it's a
last thing but but does my analogy make
sense
I think I made that up no one else has
ever said that so that's interesting say
original song but I'm right it's over
everyone's bored sex tape yeah so when
this whole charade is done yeah can you
and your brother are proven innocent yes
and you're scot-free yes walk us through
what the future holds for the Tate
Brothers the future holds more of the
same
I feel like the days when me and Andrew
were on a mission to get to the next
step we have to get here we have to get
here we have to get here that ended a
while ago and this case has now given us
one more of those we need to beat this
that's our next hurdle but I'm more
about trying to enjoy the steps than
caring about what the next one is you
know I want to spend time with my
daughter I love my I love being a dad
it's a wonderful experience I'd love to
I'd love to have more kids uh keep the
income coming in keep being rich keep
flying around on private jets
experiencing the very best things the
world has to offer the best cigars to
find the suits you know the the most
well mixed martinis at the finest hotels
in the world that's what I like to do
and there's just going to be much more
of that but I'm going to appreciate it a
lot more than if I had never been sent
to that dungeon
expect 92 days 93 days yeah 92 days
and you guys watched a very good movie
together rush hour I mean you have
access to that kind of stuff yeah
I think I think the people at the
Romanian police force are probably
studying that movie right now as well
I'm sure you've heard this story but uh
yeah and on the flight back that song is
stuck in my head right now I can't get
it out uh the ketchup song Jesus Christ
yeah fashion advice you're you're like
you know it's amazing every time you put
it together so
22 year old guys watching this how can I
get better in fashion what tips could
you give them oh there's one tip there's
one tip that overrules absolutely
everything be in shape the person who
makes my suits the same person who makes
the suits of King Charles of England now
I like I have nothing bad really to say
about King Charles but he looks worse in
his suits than I look in my suits
they're made by the same people why
because I'm in good shape a suit is all
about how it fits you it's not about I
have to be Tristan hey I'm gonna go to
Savile Row in London and I'm going to
buy a 10 000 suit no get into good shape
you know for a couple a couple hundred
bucks maybe a thousand bucks you could
put one together have your mother have
someone you know with a sewing machine
you know taper it in a little bit at the
sides make sure that the leg is the
exact right length but if you are shaped
like a like like a like a man in good
shape the suit's gonna look good on you
there's no way you can be uh obese lazy
out of shape individual and go to my
tailor and come out and come out of my
tailor shop regardless of how much you
spend looking like me be in shape is the
number one fashion device I give to
anyone it's the old old Versace t-shirt
you know on a big fat guy versus just a
plain Five Buck t-shirt on a guy who's
in shape that's my advice to young men
be in good shape and buy clothes that
fit you that overrules absolutely every
single fashion rule that anyone could
give the man makes the suit the suit
doesn't make the match absolutely
absolutely I was expecting one gray one
navy blue one this one that no three
different shape nope be in shape
possibly no one suits fine yeah so we
learn a lot today we learned the kind of
cigars you like it's half the price of
kohiwa we learned we're gonna have to
see what's going to happen with Romania
because with the case we have to kind of
wait for that we learned that these
YouTube fights is like porn celebrity we
know I'm right you're smiling because
you're not from there and we learned
that the best tip for fashionable advice
is to be in shape absolutely this has
been an incredible conversation with you
I wish we could have done it last time
I'm glad we were able to do it this time
you look good no nothing going on here
which is good but uh looking forward to
the next time hopefully next time we
talk you guys will be free and you'll be
able to tell some stories that maybe we
couldn't tell today oh absolutely I'm
looking forward to that brother this was
great yeah it's been great it's been
great if you want a guaranteed way to
get in touch with me maybe you have a
business idea maybe you want some
fashion tips maybe you just want to
connect you could find me on minute